[Music]
pewdiepie
how's it going bros my name is welcome
to
the bike we're back baby i've been on a
mini holiday
i always forget how i do my intros can
you do this
is that what i used to do oh sorry just
all the interest we can get done
leave your memes on the reddit 19 year
old
now measure your peeps
it's been a while so there should be
good memes in here i'm excited to see
what it's all about
felix playing video games alone felix
playing video games with new friends
you know it's really good when you're
trying to overcome social awkwardness
by people constantly reminding you how
socially awkward you are i appreciate
that thank you guys
what am i supposed to do are they
yelling all the time it looks so awkward
when all the people are shouting what
are they supposed to do
oh yeah i forgot you're all chance right
you come into a group of eight people
you never
you never met or talked to and you just
and they're all yelling and
you're just like no
that's even cringed too what was i
supposed to do
god damn it i'm never i'm never
venturing out of my youtube shell again
pewdiepie was sitting right next to
felix schelberg and didn't he
what this is the top voted
amazing thank you guys for letting me
know i will look into it
maybe we can track down that son of a
[ __ ] case i
oh no
[Music]
this means i have to buy one now it's
your turn
felix you but
okay fine why did i start this oh
god freaking out porn jesus christ
they're so expensive
[Music]
okay it is done you may yell louder than
me
saying but you can't play the alport
better than me
ksi it's on
avengers infinity war is the most
ambitious crossover
ever me imagine case i picks up the
outpouring he enjoys it so much
he quits rap and pulls out the
outpouring in the his concerts instead
that'd be happy more ksi memes all right
this uh reddit has taken a new turn who
is who
one is a pro boxer who has one big fight
and
proven people wrong and it's still a
legend
the other is a gamer who sits on the
floor with his dogs and watches memes
i love how you've circled my my chest
i'm guessing you're trying to insinuate
that i have mantis
well i don't okay i'm not gonna [ __ ]
show you
before can pewdiepie do this hello
huh hey guys look i'm
i'm ksi look at me ksi's freaking buff
yeah yeah yeah maybe packs a bit of
extra weight but at least he's got the
muscles underneath
i'm pure aesthetics he sheds those
titties off
booyah some some man boobs right there
some man breastsicles for everyone being
like pids looks so uncomfortable he
doesn't like
the sidemen felix admitted he gets
anxious about interacting with you
yeah all right all right all right all
right i'm stopping this meme
i'm stopping this meme i don't get
anxious
that is not a feeling i have i have no
emotions stop it
stop oh dick thunder responded hell yeah
oh my god he's real
he's a real person i am dick thunder i
asked him
every since worst nightmare all right
let's see if he's real
ask me anything i look forward to this
i need to see your driver license sir
yes i need to confirm that's real
[Laughter]
legend
oh that's [ __ ] funny richard joseph
where's the dick
huh where's the peepee thunder means
nothing without pee-pee
oh don't make me give small people to
dick thunder i can't do it
i can't even talk you know what i'm
sorry
i'm sorry you lord lord dick thunder son
uh the reason why peanuts became buff
was so much that wasn't
taken by ricardo and that's a fact
oh yeah usually when people get married
they settle down they get comfortable
they start fatting up not me
not me and also i don't get anxious
thank you now what the [ __ ] is that
jack please change glasses i can't look
at this
that's kind of sweet in a way how old is
my dad he's like 65 or something
how does he look so young he drank the
potion of youth
good genes i'll take him our son
neutron stars black holes corpse voice
heaviest object in the universe i want
to hear corpse
voice on helium it's like doing minus
infinity it doesn't change anything
oh isn't there material where that makes
the voice
deeper he'll break the sound barrier it
wouldn't be possible
have you seen how course blown up after
all the mangas
someone made the card so ivy that's
funny he deserves eight he seems like a
genuinely good dude
at least from what i can tell if felix
didn't collab with casey case i
wasted
i bought it i bought it you can calm
down you can calm down
everywhere i go i see his face
martin made me oh i have a show this she
made me one as well
i i wanted to buff one so my says furby
is called uh
spit so i wanted to name mine [ __ ] but
she didn't allow it so his name is
uh i don't know you guys name him get
today's the anniversary of pewter's
first video all right
that's cool thank you i didn't know
i gotta send this to marzia a rare look
at marcia's toy
collections check what's that
she's literally said from toy story i
wonder if she's seen this
she saw it
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh what the what is this oh
sick oh hell yeah
[Music]
oh good vibration in this video
oh yes
i like it that's cool big beepy so pewds
play with jesus himself
wait what oh oh charlie okay logic
ryan higa the seidman dream the man that
turned every
one game by just speaking i think we
know that one
and some pretty big twitch humans yet i
haven't seen him play with mr bees come
that cannot stand mr beast
let's play take a break from
sliming up and let's get some memes
yeah i'm not awkward okay nobody
felix after every sip of g fuel there it
is
someone finally did it i shaved my beer
now though we need a new version
is that good
nice yes yes
all right pewdiepie in his videos
pewdiepie on instagram
oh yeah come on i posted shirtless pick
no memes
[Laughter]
pewdiepie as a shy enemy but i'm not shy
stop it get out of it this is not
becoming a meme
i refuse we don't want to tape the tape
now
oh okay i got it we just want felix to
play mark
and among us all right mr beast and mark
it is
come on huge hates edgar also kills i
love that
come on he's my little teddy bear cocoa
melon has interfered
it's for me thank you
big brain ksi our expectations were low
but holy [ __ ]
him i may not be the best in posture
because i never get impostor anyway
but i'm the best crewmate i know who it
is every time
my gut corpse voice everyone else's
voice
lily's voice that's kind of wholesome by
the way right
hey among us means i need this food pie
intro what
holy sh
all right med scan
[Music]
bravo if you see this have a nice day i
hope you're doing great staying strong
epic big peepee right there
guys the truth hurts hard to swallow
pills pewdiepie edition
who's didn't miss your posting lawyer he
just didn't find it funny
or scythe didn't find it funny
huh you ever thought of that the oompa
loompa support peers oh
yeah the opelompus is on our side cocoa
melon close to passing periods
me and the boys were all the camps come
on oppaloompas
the year is 20 50 the years 2069
it's melon vs man the battle scene lost
but in the last moment at broof is deep
from the midst of the mountains a sound
appears from oopaloompus
referee pewdiepie here to judge your
peepee sorry shave the beard
looks nothing like me what do you think
about that [ __ ]
you can really do the split eh as you
might know a war broke out in armenia
many had
to part with their family members my
father volunteered to take part as
command himself
i wanted to know how much he means to me
and others in a similar state thank you
felix and the bros
for always making us happier oh
hope your family is well and safe fellow
nine-year-old
thank you for i'm glad my video is going
to help
you guys get distracted from whatever
you're going through
hey felix listen all kidding aside oh
i took my mask off um oh he's got two of
her in the back so it is for me
marzia a belated happy anniversary you
and i kind of went through the same sort
of thing you married a foreigner
so i think we have a lot in common so
take care for now
and i'll see
that's crazy hey big end
big big ups to you man am i am i
watching a commercial
or am i watching a message not i can't
tell
but apparently big edit masks are
available guys
i made it a little less sincere but hey
i'll take it
it took me 27 years to grow some beards
huge beard
yeah it's an on and off switch basically
oh
dear the imposter oh yeah
i gotta go yellow next time
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
the real reason i work out oh you're
approaching oh people got their
teammates getting sick
hey
[Music]
hell yeah oh [ __ ]
right there
oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
no
i never realized i had got it
[Music]
[Laughter]
it needs to react to this
it's a really well animated music video
about the past 10 years
[Music]
whoa what the [ __ ] that's like
the most perfectly rendered that looks
exactly like the kitchen
[Music]
hey
i feel like
[Music]
come on hey whiskey nice
100 now 100 more i'm beautiful
oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
holy [ __ ] bad history
go sub that's it
[Music]
i'm blown away by that holy [ __ ]
the song was really good first of all
but also i'm blown away by the details
oh
it's like looking at my oh how did they
get it so detailed
oh my god that is so like even the
headphones
they must
every like that's my old keyboard that's
my old keyboard they're
so detailed they didn't just like take
an old keyboard that's what oh my god
i used to have exactly that setup that
is my room that is lit
i used to have that lamp they literally
rendered that lamp and that thing i
added there oh what
even the painting and the r2d2
and yeah i used to have a bunch of
movies and [ __ ] in there
it's so oh my god
[Music]
it's even emotional just looking at it
it's like following the whole journey in
a weird
really weird way even my outfit
it's perfect absolutely perfect
i don't know what to say just thank you
thank you so much uh
all right all right i found a flaw you
should have said this is so insane
right
thank you i can't follow up with that
with anything maybe i'll make a part two
lawyer this week
i don't know but just thank you guys so
much
for all the memes everything you do i am
so
lucky to have such an awesome fan base
that is so cool
that's only one thing to do thanks for
watching guys i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]